[Music]
this is my house
oh my gosh
i can't even believe this is my house
it's
gorgeous
[Applause]
oh i'm so happy to meet you in person
and what i'm more excited about this
living room are you
good that's what i wanted
[Applause]
we put like so much thought into every
little detail our face timing
zooming really paid off i love who you
are and i love what you do and i
love where you're at in life and like we
just
kept that all in mind picking each and
every little thing out for you
thank you come sit down for a second on
your
beautiful new white couch i want to say
a special thanks to burke decor
we were able to make this room
the exact one we were hoping to which
was really chic
really elevated celebratory
one of the things i really put into
question was what
section of the wall do we make dark and
we ended up falling in love with this
wall but then we wanted to carry it
through
so that you can camouflage the tv
as well in a chic way i'm like the
biggest fan
of poster art like exhibition art
because you can have all these
amazing artists in your room for an
affordable price
this kitchen was just so fun
to work on because it taught me how to
bring more of like a living room vibe
to a table rather than a kitchen table
if you have your
kitchen table seen from the living room
make it more living room looking because
this is the visual
vantage that you have we knew that we
wanted to do something
dark on this wall so it reflected the
darkness in there and then we brought
the poster art
over to bring in once again the other
room
there's visual things that are
represented in both rooms
that are the same and that's what helps
bring it together
we found these great lights so the flush
mount
in the kitchen matches this light so
this room is brought into each other as
well
and you want to think about that like
cohesive way
i can't even believe this is my kitchen
thanks to our friends at lg we
got this fantastic refrigerator i got
you
a stove from lg to match the lightness
in your kitchen
i think a good fresh start to like
new chi new life fresh appliances
love it and i'm so excited how is it
going at your work right now
well right now things are seeming to get
a little bit better but there was such a
dark time
that just seeing how sick people got and
how
fast and how unexpected it really gives
you a new appreciation for life
and for family and for your health
and just to be fortunate to have health
you sit down for a second and just to
see
families that you know their loved ones
were so sick and they couldn't even come
and see them in the hospital
it's just heartbreaking you know what
nurses are
resilient yes how do you stay resilient
i'm a firm believer of what's meant to
be is meant to be and
you have to be kind and you have to just
do your best every day
and hopefully you won't have fear
i feel like you're so wise and i
really want to it's going to go on my
gratitude list
today for sure is you and
just everything we've talked about
i feel that i don't know you as a person
i just know from what i see on
television
and you make me happy you're always
smiling and you always are so full of
this like beautiful
energy and this house now when i walk in
here
every time i come in here i'm going to
be so grateful
and i'm just going to feel such positive
energy
and it's going to make me smile and i
just am i'm so
thankful and i love you and everything
you have done for me
i'm i'm just i'm so touched thank you
okay
i wish i could surprise you from behind
the chair every time you walked in
every time i walk in i am going to smile
regardless of
the day that i've had or i mean
i'm so happy so proud this is gonna be
my home
thank you it was so amazing getting to
know kate
while we transformed her home she really
is a hero
and she just deserves every good thing
that's coming to her and i want to ask
you a question
do you need help designing a space i
would love to be your designer would you
like to be a client
i live for this go to our website and
write to us
[Music]